Hey folks, we're going to talk
about meditation for a second.
I get a lot of questions
about how to start meditating.
Keeping in mind that I had a,
a very severe allergy to the word and
concept of meditation for a very long
time,
more than a decade,
and I've only really consistently
started meditating and,
uh, implemented meditating for
the last two to three years.
There are few easy ways to get started,
but before I talk about that,
what is meditation?
There are a few ways you can look at it.
I think the simplest way to look at it
as a type a personality is either as a
warm bath for your mind so
that you relax in such a way.
Maybe it's only 10% to reduce your
anxiety so you can be more effective and
productive, less reactive, in other words,
don't get carried away by knee
jerk emotions and judgments,
obsessing on the past,
something that happened or something
in the future planning, etc.
You're able to actually single task
and focus. That is one of the outcomes,
one of the benefits of different
types of meditating. All right.
And that can take the form of something
very short or something a little more
involved.
I'll talk about both the other,
and this is why I think meditation
can be viewed in a way as
stoic training or a in
some ways similar to CBT,
cognitive behavioral therapy because
the objective is to help you to observe
your state and your thoughts so that
you are less controlled by them.
What does this mean? I'll
use an analogy that, uh,
I think was originally shared
with me by Andy Puddicombe, uh,
who is the founder of
something called headspace,
which I'll talk about in a second,
which is the difference in effect being,
say,
standing out in the storm,
getting pelted with rain and hail and
wind and staying in your eyes and so on,
being soaking wet or standing inside,
looking through the glass at the storm.
The ladder is meditation the way I've put
it before, which is slightly different.
It's the difference between being in
the washing machine or standing outside
looking into the washing machine.
And when you have that somewhat
detached observer perspective,
you can just be much calmer,
much more appreciative,
and ultimately effective.
I do not think that meditation
causes you to lose your edge.
This was a concern of mine and I think
it's a concern of a lot of type a driven
people.
But even if it did cause you to lose
saying 10% who cares ultimately are trying
to succeed and make more
money and do all these things,
build a bigger business to improve the
quality of life for yourself, for others.
And you achieve that I
think more directly, uh,
in many cases by even if you had to take,
say,
a 10% haircut on your edge by improving
your present state awareness by,
uh, much, much more, 50
to a hundred percent.
So let's jump into a couple of
options, right? So if you're not a dog,
because dogs are always present,
state aware,
then you need some human tools.
One option,
and this is the way I
started very early on,
meditating was listening to one song.
So find one song that puts you into a
good mood and in the morning all you're
going to do is sit comfortably.
So this could be sitting in a chair,
feet on the floor,
just like this.
Hands in your lap,
you generally you're going to want
some type of backs and forth. Uh,
you do not need a dog
chewing on a squeaky toy.
So I may intervene molecule here,
camp or you can sit like this,
which is how I tend to sit when I
meditate. So this is not full lotus,
this is half lotus,
not even half load.
It's really just one foot tucked
into the crease of my calf and thigh.
And then I'm going to kind
of pull the butt cheeks.
So then I have a nice little seat here,
back flat and then my hands are either
going to be in my lap like so or I will
actually post my hands
on my thighs like this,
which can also help if you have a
tendency of slouching to keep your back
straight. All right, listen
to one song. For me it was a,
we're going to party
like it's 1999 prince.
It's hard to be as stressed
out worrying about things.
If you listen to that song, trust me,
you can pick whatever poison you like,
but this was shared with me by Kemal
Robert Kahn and he suggested listening to
one song doing nothing in particular
other than listening to the song and
breathing, and that's three
to four minutes. That's it.
So you could try that in the morning.
That was one of the first approaches
I took. The second approach,
which I think is very,
very effective and best for many people
is some form of guided meditation.
This means that instead of sitting by
yourself and being completely dependent on
whatever's happening in your mind and
developing that skill of observation,
you're listening to something.
And that could be any number
of different types of audio.
So one would be,
and there are many different types and
recorded guided meditations by people
like Sam Harris.
So same harris.org he is a neuroscience
phd or Tara Brock said Tara Brock,
B R,
a,
c h who I've had on the podcast and fair
shell has a fantastic audio called the
2010 summer smile meditation.
You can find it for free and some
incredible folks like Maria Popova for
instance,
who runs brain pickings,
listened to that every morning and credit
it with a really changing their lives.
So those are two you can find immediately
just searching right after this video.
You can also use guided meditation
that is more progressive.
It's almost like weight training.
There's progressive resistance
or progressive difficulty
and there are many good
options out there. So I've used say
headspace for weeks and weeks at time.
Uh, it is a very easy way to
meditate. Also, if you're,
say sitting in a plane or sitting in a
car and you can drop in your ear phones
and you're good to go,
another would be calm.
There are a number of different
varieties and options here.
Let's say that you've listened this
far in. You're like, God, I just,
I'm not some hippy woo person.
I just want to perform better.
Really don't care about this thing
that you're calling meditation. Okay,
well I have an option for you
because even in my own mind,
I wonder when I see the
benefits of meditation, which
are generally better sleep,
less dependence on caffeine,
you become much more sensitive to
things like caffeine and alcohol. Uh,
better ability to execute and
focus on the important things.
So maybe I'm not doing a hundred things.
I'm doing 20,
but the 20 or better thought through
and more important, in fact, uh,
I wonder though,
is the benefit coming from simply sitting
with really good posture for 10 to 20
minutes?
Is it coming from the breathing?
Is it coming from closing my
eyes and doing the breathing?
Is it coming from the exercise that
I'm doing inside my own head river that
might be, or something else? I happen to
think a lot of it is from the breathing.
All right?
Now if you then want to skip meditation,
you could download an APP
called apnea trainer, uh,
which has pranayama breathing and
it is designed for free divers.
I do not recommend doing any of these
breathing exercises before getting in
water. You can cause yourself a lot of
trouble unless you have highly qualified
professional instruction.
Okay. But the apnea trainer,
which was introduced to me by Gabby Reese,
who's married to Laird Hamilton,
so Gabby, incredible world class athlete
in her own right. And then layered,
who is the,
I think most people would
say the undisputed King of
Big Wave Surfing at least
was for decades,
introduced me to this and it will have
you do different types of breathing
patterns and we'll count you down.
So it might say five seconds.
Inhale five second,
hold ten second, exhale,
five second holds.
That would be one type that you could
use plenty amo or you could do something
like five seconds. Inhale
22nd, hold ten second exhale.
And then back to repeat that cycle
and just listening to the counting and
breathing along with it. I find to
be extremely calming and centering.
Uh, I almost do all of my meditation
earlier in the day, in the morning.
I try to do it before
turning on the phone.
So if you look at my phone right now,
well first it was a coyote on it,
but that's a longer story.
There is an airplane icon up here in the
corner because I almost always have my
phone on airplane mode when I go to bed.
It's an airplane mode and I try not to
turn it on because you then you get the
barrage of bullets, IEE, text messages,
and different notifications, which
immediately puts you into a reactive mode.
So before that, I like to
meditate, feed my pooch, et cetera.
And then, and only then, maybe after some
journaling, turn on the phone. All right,
other options for meditation
if you really want to into it.
What caused it to finally stick for me?
And now I can play around with
all these different options.
But what really got me to
meditate consistently was
taking a class and I took a
transmittal meditation class.
That's tm.org.
These are not cheap. I think there's
somewhere between a thousand and $2,000,
which is in my mind, kind of silly. Uh,
but Rick Rubin,
legendary music producer had asked
me if I'd ever tried TM at one point.
And then, uh, I took his advice, but I, I,
I looked into it and I decided that I
don't want to have to pay 1000 bucks for
someone to give me a month from
what the hell's a mantra? Anyway,
it's very skeptical, but continued
to be very, very stressed out.
And then Chase Jarvis,
it was a very well known photographer
and CEO of critical and creative,
live creative, live.com.
Check it out. It's fantastic.
I said, what do you have
to lose? You can afford it.
So even if it ends up being a complete
waste of money now he was the second
person saying, I do TM twice
a day. Why not just do it?
You can afford to lose it even if
it's a total waste of time. So I did.
And Lo and behold,
having someone to be accountable
to who was teaching me every day,
generally during lunch hour and in between
sessions was giving me the homework
assignment of to meditation sessions,
which I then had to report back on it,
discuss with sed teacher.
It was enough social pressure to get me
to finally do it twice a day for four or
five days, and at that point
that started an unbroken streak.
I want to say I have about a year and a
half of meditating at least once a day,
often twice a day. So that
was really, I would say,
one of the tipping points for me,
if you want to get the gist of TM,
and there's some weird aspects of the
organization that I'm not a huge fan of,
but it's,
it's surprisingly secular.
Once you get past the first
meeting and the first meeting,
you have to bring fruit and flowers and
they make an offering to the founder and
it's a little culty. But once you
get past that, then it's like, okay,
what do you do?
If you're in a hotel and room service
comes in and you're halfway through
meditation, what do you do? Do
you stop? Do you talk to them?
Do you just ignore them? What are the
coping mechanisms? So it's very tactical,
practical in my experience.
Uh,
but they insist that you need someone
sort of as life support indefinitely to
teach UTM. The basics
are, you get a mantra, uh,
I think they're probably
all two syllables.
And if you want it to get a flavor for
what that type of meditation is like,
although I do think there's incredible
value in having a teacher who holds you
accountable, you could take, and
they would disagree with this,
but you could take some two syllable
word could be nonsense or not.
You could use nature, right?
Nature, nature, nature,
and say that over and over and literally
you're effectively just repeating that
ad nauseum for the period of time in
which you're doing the meditation for
trends and the meditation.
And the generally recommend 20 minutes,
first thing in the morning,
and then 20 minutes, let's say,
is chase does it right
before dinner. All right? Uh,
I almost always just do
the morning meditation.
Back in the day I was more diligent
about doing it twice a day.
I do think there's a lot of value there,
but if you just get it in the morning,
there is a lot of value to be had.
And beyond that,
I would say if you wanted
to start super small,
you could just do an experiment and
the experiment is not 20 minutes in the
morning, not 30 minutes, twice a day.
It's not a long guided meditation,
nothing like that. And by the way,
the apps I mentioned are generally
a modifiable in terms of duration.
So you do 10 minutes, 15. I did, I did 10,
four weeks at a time when I was
on book deadline for instance.
But let's make it even shorter. What you
could try. They're two different types.
So one is something that I started doing
for myself whenever I would get anxious
or I felt myself may
be getting angry or uh,
a ground swell of emotion that I
felt was unpleasant or unproductive,
I would take what I call
the three breaths break.
So three rough break is exactly what it
sounds like. You stop what you're doing.
That's one.
Just do that three times and it's
amazing how well that diffuses what could
otherwise become really
stupid or rash decisions, uh,
and pretty easy.
So try to remember to do a three breath
break and you could do that for a day or
two.
And very important,
set that intention in the morning set
that is a clear objective for the day.
And then at night review
how often you used it,
when you could have
used it when you didn't.
This type of pre and post
game is very important.
If you're going to do an experiment
with something very small like that.
And then I would say
the next you could test,
and this was in my latest book, tools of
titans, but the basic gist, this is a,
I believe his loving kindness meditation.
But forget about the label
because it sounds too woo
woo and it's weird sounding,
but, uh, Meng, so chade Meng ton,
who was previously at Google's,
one of the very early engineers,
he developed a course at Google
available to employees called,
I think it was search inside yourself.
And it quickly became the most
popular course within Google.
Thousands of employees.
There's a waitlist for I think six months.
And I taught many different tools laid
to mindfulness and meditation and one of
them which end,
he tells a story that is in tools of
titans about a woman who tried it.
I'd never done meditation before and she
said, I had my best day in seven years.
Okay,
well what provoked that?
It's a very simple approach and I've
heard said a number of people have said
before that,
uh,
I think Andy I mentioned before has also
said 10 minutes of meditating on other
people or the wider world is
worth 10 hours of meditating
on yourself. All right,
so let's assume that's true.
One very easy way to test
that out is when you're doing,
say you're three breath break
or you just take a few minutes,
five minutes to sit down and
in the morning for instance,
or whenever you're feeling stressed out,
think about a few people you're grateful
for and then wish them to be happy.
That's it. So you just imagine three
people you're really grateful for.
They could be new relationships,
old relationships,
maybe childhood friends who
haven't seen in a really long time,
teachers for long ago.
Think about them and then you're just
going to wish them happiness and hope that
they are happy and hold that
in your mind for a few minutes.
It sounds so silly and so simple.
Uh,
yet that is what this woman did
where she was in her office.
And I think every hour she thought of
a coworker and wish them happiness.
And she did that for a few hours and I
had the best day in the office I've had
in seven years. So you can try that also.
Very, very simple. So if you're like, ah,
I don't want to think about my breath or
my, this, my, that, track my thoughts,
I'm too scattered rent,
blah, blah. Okay, fine.
Just think about a handful of
other people, two or three and uh,
wish them happiness.
It's so simple.
I did this when I was finishing tools of
titans or I was about two thirds of the
way through and I was overseas and I did
a sauna every night because a bunch of
my guests do is every night.
So I started doing it and I would sit
there and it's sometimes we doing editing
by hand. I get too sweaty, get to
a point where I couldn't do that.
And I would sit there and I'll do
this loving kindness meditation.
And I remember getting to the end of the
week and thinking to myself and asking,
why am I so happy?
I mean,
you kind of know you need to fix
things if you asked yourself that.
But I tend to be pretty tightly wound,
a very aggressive and I focused a lot
more on achievement than say contentment
or happiness in most of my life.
But man,
that week was amazing and there
were other elements as well.
But the main variable that I tweaked
was this tiny, tiny exercise.
And so in meditation,
as in everything else,
I think it pays to look for the very
little tweaks that have very big payoffs.
So hopefully that helps.
Those are a few of the things that helped
me to develop a mindfulness meditation
habit.
And last but not least,
if you meditate for a period of time
and then you fall off the train,
don't beat yourself up.
Just get back on the train.
It doesn't do any good to self
flagellate because you missed one or two
meditation sessions.
This isn't the Olympics of meditating.
So just get back on and uh,
then you will see the results and you
then have the recipe that you can use
anytime you want. Thanks for
watching guys. I hope you enjoyed it.
And if you want to see more,
I have some fantastic stuff coming,
including collaborations. Just click
here and you'll be the first to see it.